les rejets aider à prouver que si
l'europe voulait imposer à des
entreprises américaines dont le maître
mot c'est celle à la non friction de
leur interface un service absolument
parfait dans lesquelles elles et les
utilisateurs ne quitte jamais le site
web on peut perturber leur expérience
comme ça l'europe a réussi à le faire
la chine peut être vu aussi de manière
très très cynique comme une bonne
nouvelle parce que j'ai entendu
l'europe est trop en retard pour pour m
mettre à jour son son économie numérique
ces technologies numériques
je pense que l'europe est pas aussi en
retard technologiquement que l'était la
chine ya 20 ans sauf que en 20 ans en
déclarant de manière très nette
ce que la chine voulait faire avec son
internet et l'internet chinois est
véritablement à l'image de ce que le
parti communiste chinois veut faire de
sa société la question de est ce que
cette souveraineté numérique européenne
doit être faite dans une alliance
transatlantique
est ce que pour reprendre le terme
d'assaut mal de tout à l'heure la
manière dont les données personnelles
sont gérés par les gaffes à sont un
malentendu jeu ça me semble pas évident
parce que si on regarde si on regarde
quelque chose de très américain et de
très européen comme la santé la manière
dont on gère l'assurance maladie ou en
europe de manière très caricatural on a
une sécurité sociale
aux états unis on achète son assurance
santé
donc pour résumer je me demande quels
seraient les modalités de cette
organisation transatlantique ce qu'elle
apporterait par rapport à internet
society et si les états unis comme seul
interlocuteur serait véritablement le
bon interlocuteur pour mettre en place
notre propre internet utopique dans la
vision européenne
[Musique]